und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend beginnen wir mal nicht mit dem
aktuellsten thema sondern mit dem
schwersten der tag brachte eine
erinnerung daran was für ein brutaler
einschnitt der neunte oktober in halle
an der saale war
jom kippur der höchste feiertag des
jüdischen jahres hätte diese alte
holztür der synagoge den schüssen nicht
standgehalten
dann wäre eine jüdische gemeinde im
gebet versammelt ausgelöscht worden
mehr als 80 jahre nach der
reichspogromnacht 1938 wäre geschehen
was für alle zeiten undenkbar geworden
sein musste überall vor allem aber in
deutschland
heute kam der präsident des jüdischen
weltkongresses dem weltbund aller
jüdischen gemeinden aus new york nach
halle
er hatte etwas zu sagen vor allem aber
wollte er zu hören lara hoffmann war
dabei ronald lauder macht sich selbst
ein bild davon was hier vor zweieinhalb
wochen passiert ist
er hat mit so einem großen gehör
der vorstand der jüdischen gemeinde in
halle max priwo roski nimmt ihn mit
er und seine gemeindemitglieder zeigen
ihnen wie sie das attentat erlebt und
überlebt haben und diese zu bestellen
diese diese türe zu ronald lauder kommt
als mensch unaufgeregt keine
presseankündigung im vorfeld kein
medienrummel
wir begleiten ihn als einziges
fernsehteam in die synagoge seine
botschaft ist deutlich
taten statt worte wir müssen gegen all
die verschiedenen neonazi gruppen
vorgehen
es sollten keine menschen egal wo in der
politik arbeiten die antisemitisch
denken wir sollten gesetze ändern und
wir sollten sie stringenter formulieren
ronald lauder stellt selbst auch viele
fragen möchte wissen wie für jüdisches
leben in halle anfühlt aber nicht so der
präsident des jüdischen weltkongresses
sagt einer der gründe für antisemitismus
sei dass gerade jüngere generationen
keinen bezug mehr hätten zum holocaust
sie wüssten nicht mehr was damals
wirklich passiert sei wir sind jetzt
drei generationen weiter sind kinder der
kinder der kinder sie haben keine ahnung
die eltern reden nicht mehr darüber die
meisten der großeltern sind schon
gestorben
sie hören nicht die wahrheit und
manchmal ist die wahrheit begraben das
ist so wichtig halle ist ein weckruf für
deutschland beim gespräch wird klar der
vorstand der jüdischen gemeinde in halle
max privat ski sieht das anders
aber ist der central & generation schon
beispiel die leute sind wir gegen oder
es ist also wahrscheinlich umgekehrt
also junge leute sind gegen die
semitismus also er ist der menschen gibt
es auch aber ich sehe immer viele junge
bzw
leute wie er und dann noch junge kinder
die um sehr starke unterstützung wo man
es ist einer dieser jüngeren leute in
der gemeinde während des anschlags war
er mit in der synagoge seinen wunsch
richtete er an alle ich will einfach nur
mehr zivilcourage was die politik macht
es war schön aber muss die
zivilgesellschaft muss haben sind man
muss die menschen und animieren die da
draußen mich die politiker nicht die
polizei ronald lauder besucht auch den
zweiten anschlagsort den kiez dünner
halle verlässt der präsident des
jüdischen weltkongresses mit gemischten
gefühlen
ich bin auf der einen seite betrübt aber
auf der anderen seite wenn ich die
blumen sehe bin ich auch optimistisch
optimistisch dass deutschland wie andere
länder auch wie die usa über solche
taten hinauswachsen kann
es ist nur zu schaffen wenn die menschen
wirklich verstehen damit das gelingt
braucht es wie hohn alt lotter fordert
taten statt worte es sind die letzten
tage jetzt des wahlkampfes um den
landtag von thüringen übermorgen wird
gewählt
alle umfragen auch unsere letzte von
gestern ergeben eine sagen wir mal
reizvolle situation
die links partei des ministerpräsidenten
ramelow liegt derzeit vorne was die
linkspartei bisher nirgends jemals
geschafft hat cdu und fdp im mittelfeld
die anderen sind einstellig der reiz
entsteht weil niemand etwas mit der afg
zu tun haben will
und das heißt cdu und linkspartei
müssten sich nach allen anderen seiten
offen halten um irgendwie eine mehrheit
zu dritt oder zu viert zu bauen oder
linkspartei und cdu müssten zusammen
gehen dass das wäre alles neuland
oder es gebe eine minderheitsregierung
das wäre dann neuland mit glatter
interessant schade dass im schlussspurt
darüber keiner laut reden will
andreas postel bericht bunte hände in
zeulenroda für einen thüringen ohne hass
und hetze der wahlkampf war in den
vergangenen wochen ruppig es gab
morddrohungen zerstörte plakate
abgebrannte lkw so polarisiert war der
freistaat seit 30 jahren nicht mehr
und das liegt auch an ihm thüringens afg
spitzenkandidaten küren höcke der für
interviews nicht zur verfügung steht
niemand will mit ihm koalieren sein
völkischen nationaler flügel wird vom
verfassungsschutz als verdachtsfall
eingestuft trotzdem erreicht er mit
seinem kurs laut umfragen mehr als 20
prozent von dieser polarisierung
profitierte amtsinhaber 54 prozent der
thüringer wünschen sich derzeit bodo
ramelow als ministerpräsident und der
würde die rot rot grüne koalition auch
gern fortsetzen
alle in deutschland gedacht das geht gar
nicht und mit einer stimme mehrheit
schon grad gar nicht und deswegen haben
wir jetzt erfolgreich gezeigt es geht
und wir hätten gerne da wir gute
umfragewerte haben das gibt bürger auch
sich entscheiden und sagen wenn wir
jetzt schon die arbeit gut finden dann
wäre es auch freundlich wenn man das
kreuzchen bei rot rot grün macht die
linke stark aber die partner schwäche
si
die sozialdemokratie ist in ihrem
stammland seit wochen vor allem
einstellig wolfgang tiefensee fällt es
nicht leicht den eigenen anteil an der
thüringer regierungsbilanz
rüberzubringen
der bundestrend macht ihnen zu schaffen
wir brauchen eine starke spd in einer
rot-rot-grünen regierung das ist die aus
balancierende die stabilisierende kraft
in den letzten fünf jahren gewesen und
mit unseren drei ressorts finanzen
wirtschaft und inneres haben wir sehr
gute arbeit geleistet
cdu-herausforderer mike mohring ist da
ganz anderer meinung und kämpft an
diesem abend in nordhausen ebenfalls mit
prominenter unterstützung darum die
staatskanzlei in thüringen für die cdu
zurück zu erobern
wir können weder mit der afg die
rückwärtsgewandte politik macht zukunft
gestalten noch mit der linken die wir
ablösen wollen und die sich nur in der
gegenwart beschreibung auffällt und dann
liegt genau der unterschied wir wollen
nach vorn schauen wollen thüringen an
die spitze der deutschen länder bringe
das geht nur mit einer regierung in der
mitte bündnis 90 die grünen wollen
eigentlich mit bodo ramelow weiter
regieren und hoffen am ende auf die
entscheidenden zwei bis drei prozent 30
jahre nach der friedlichen revolution
ist auch die jüngste debatte um den ddr
unrechtsstaats begriff kein bremsklotz
mehr klimaschutz und demokratie das sind
die großen themen von bündnis 90/die
grünen und wer will dass rot-rot-grün
fortgesetzt wird mit einer starken
umweltministerin beispielsweise an der
spitze der muss am sonntag bei bündnis
90 die grünen
viel hängt davon ab ob die fdp mit
spitzenkandidat thomas kemmerich den
einzug in den landtag schafft über 30
prozent der wahlberechtigten sind noch
unentschlossen besonders um diese
stimmen geht es jetzt beim
wahlkampfendspurt in thüringen vor gut
drei jahren im juli 2016 überstürzten
sich eilmeldungen aus münchen neun tote
wurden gemeldet vom olympia
einkaufszentrum gestorben im kugelhagel
aus schnellfeuerwaffen aus den
unterschiedlichsten ecken von münchen
wurden danach angebliche weitere
schießereien gemeldet
alles gemahnte an den terror tag von
paris im november davor start de france
und bata klar wo 130 menschen starben
und das netz lief damals über über mit
forderungen dass die medien doch endlich
zu geben sollten
islamistischer terror sei es war aber
alles anders
völlig anders auch das motiv nun auch
offiziell in den nachrichten das
bayerische landeskriminalamt hat die tat
neu bewertet und als politisch motiviert
eingestuft die erkenntnisse aus drei
jahren ermittlungsarbeit und experten
gutachten hätten zahlreiche
anhaltspunkte für eine rechtsextreme und
rassistische orientierung des 18
jährigen schülers ergeben
ursprünglich hatten die ermittler die
tat als racheakt eines psychisch kranken
für mobbing gesehen
opfervertreter sowie spd und grüne
hatten das immer kritisiert und begrüßen
nun die neubewertung die meisten der
neun todesopfer waren jung und hatten
einen migrationshintergrund
der bundestag hat über erste teile des
klimapaketes 2030 der bundesregierung
debattiert als gute basis verteidigte
spd umweltministerin schulze etwa das
klimaschutzgesetz es sorge für klare
regeln wie viel treibhausgas in
einzelnen bereichen wie verkehr
landwirtschaft oder gebäude ausgestoßen
werden darf den grünen gehen die pläne
nicht weit genug und die fdp sieht
planwirtschaftlichen ballast die afg
sprach von einem verbots und
steuererhöhungs programm
die ministerpräsidenten befürworten die
klimaschutzmaßnahmen wehren sich aber
dagegen dass das klima paket des bundes
finanziell zulasten der länder geht zum
abschluss ihrer konferenz forderten sie
eine vollständige kompensation der
steuerausfälle für die länder und
kommunen von geschätzt jährlich 500
millionen euro etwa durch die absenkung
der mehrwertsteuer auf bahntickets
bund und länder wollen schneller auf
lebensmittelkrisen wie etwa keine in
fleisch reagieren darauf haben sich
bundesministerin klöckner und vertreter
der länder verständigt das system der
lebensmittelkontrollen sei zwar nur
erklärte klöckner es gebe aber
optimierungsbedarf so sollen unternehmen
künftig ihre lieferlisten digital
bereitstellen
außerdem soll eine zentrale datenbank zu
keim funden rückrufe beschleunigen
verbraucherschützer fordern eine
deutlich strengere überwachung der
hersteller im irak sind nach
dreiwöchiger ruhe wieder proteste gegen
die regierung gegen korruption und
arbeitslosigkeit aufgeflammt tausende
demonstranten zogen zum
regierungsviertel was sicherheitskräfte
versuchten zu verhindern
beim einsatz auch scharfe munition
sollen 21 menschen getötet und mehr als
1700 verletzt worden sein
anfang oktober waren bei tagelangen
protesten fast 150 zivilisten getötet
worden
im streit über den ausgang der
präsidentschaftswahl in bolivien haben
sich die europäische union und die
bundesregierung für eine stichwahl
ausgesprochen wahlbeobachter hatten
große unregelmäßigkeiten bei der
auszählung kritisiert in der nacht
eskalierten proteste gegen amtsinhaber
morales der hatte sich zuvor zum
wahlsieger erklärt nach offiziellen
angaben ist der abstand zum
oppositionskandidaten so groß dass keine
stichwahl gebraucht werde
bei den anstrengungen den klimawandel zu
bremsen hat der mensch verbündete bäume
durch wälder und holznutzung wird in
deutschland ein siebtel des co2
ausstoßes eingespart aber den wald geht
es schlecht
heiße trockene jahre am laufenden band
formieren sich zu einem veränderten
klima dass die bäume anfälliger macht
für stürme und schädlinge das hat
bedrohliche ausmaße angenommen aber der
mensch ist ja nicht nur ein schädling er
kann nützliche dinge erfinden auch um zu
helfen und sei es ein fliegender
spürhund in dieser patch mit berichtet
diese buche ist zu gefährlich geworden
trocken gestresst brüchig drohte sie auf
die straße zu fallen
der steilhang im thüringer wald zu
riskant für gängige fell methoden
deshalb musste die bundeswehr an
mit einem sprengkommando das buch im
sterben hält auch förster in
niedersachsen in atem
seit den 80er jahren pflanzen sie hier
im harz buchen und andere laubbäume um
fichten monokulturen zugeschneit
umzubauen
doch die jungen buchen vertragen wie
viele sonne und hitze nicht unter den
momentanen umständen bekommen sie von
beidem zu viel ab es ist ein drama unser
wald ist ganz angegriffenen zustand das
möchte ich mir nicht vorstellen dass die
heimischen baumarten uns verloren gehen
aber wir werden eine verschiebung des
artenspektrum zu erleben
110000 hektar wald sind allein im
vergangenen jahr verloren gegangen eine
fläche so groß wie berlin und potsdam
zusammen
die buche gilt durch ihre längeren
wurzeln eigentlich als trocken als
resistenter im vergleich zur fichte
doch auch in den sägewerken zeigen sich
mittlerweile die folgen der vergangenen
trockenen sommer viele buchenstämme
haben pilz befallen sie sehen hier diese
verfärbungen das ist so genannter
schleim fluss und das geht leider durch
den ganzen stamm der länge nach einmal
durchführen sind kunden wollen
makelloses helles holz für tische stühle
oder fußböden
doch der pilz beginnt das buchenholz zu
zersetzen es wird brüchig
das hat kein handeln da in forst und
holzwirtschaft je erlebt ich befürchte
schon dass im winter das im winter schon
in einigen monaten schon holz das heute
noch zu verwenden wäre in drei vier fünf
monaten vielleicht nicht mehr verwendet
werden kann auch mit diesem schädling
kämpfen die trockenen wälder borkenkäfer
haben in den vergangenen beiden jahren
fast 70 millionen kubikmeter fichtenholz
zerstört forscher der universitäten
göttingen rottenburg und freiburg
arbeiten mit einer firma aus bayern an
dieser spezial drohne über gassensoren
soll sie wie ein flug spürhund herz
geruch erschnüffeln
bäume herzen wenn sich käfer in ihre
rinde bohren der vorteil ist dass man
mit dieser methode wenn wir sie dann zum
funktionieren bringen
sehr früh einen befall diktieren kann in
etwa drei bis vier monate früher kann
man dran sein bevor man überhaupt an
baumschäden sieht bis die drohne
verlässliche daten liefert wird es
mindestens noch ein jahr dauern ein
hoffnungsschimmer doch die
klimaveränderungen die verbauten käfer
und pilze verantwortlich sind stellen
auch wissenschaftler vor immer größere
herausforderungen
jetzt fällt die fichte aus die buche
fällt aus und wir sind ehrlich gesagt
ratlos was wir jetzt empfehlen sollen
auch jetzt in der zukunft anzupflanzen
in den wäldern können förster zurzeit
nur schadensbegrenzung betreiben
fest steht jeder tote baum kann kein co2
mehr speichern
die grüne lunge liegt bereits auf der
intensivstation
am letzten freitag im oktober 1929 von
90 jahren also erreichte das große beben
in new york europa an der wall street
waren die kurse zusammengebrochen es
brauchte tage bis das ausmaß der
katastrophe klar wurde banken und
industrieunternehmen brachen zusammen
jede vierte arbeitnehmer in den usa war
in der arbeitslos und arbeitslosigkeit
ist damals absturz ins elend
bis heute ist dieser crash der die welt
in eine tiefe depression stürzte
einzigartig geblieben
wenn man an diesem jahrestag daran mit
grausen erinnert dann geht der blick
natürlich auch bank nach vorne könnte so
etwas wieder passieren nicht genau so
sagen experten aber ähnlich genug dara
hassanzadeh
die goldenen 20er jahre selbst im
spätsommer 1929 ahnt noch niemand dass
die weltwirtschaft vor dem kollaps steht
den menschen geht es nach dem ersten
weltkrieg wieder besser die zukunft
scheint rosarot im september erreichte
der dow jones sein allzeithoch millionen
amerikaner kaufen aktien oft auf pump im
vertrauen auf weiter steigende kurse
am 24 oktober gegen 11 uhr platzt die
blase panik an der wall street zu viele
verschuldete anleger müssen verkaufen
kaum einer will mehr kaufen die kurse
fallen ins bodenlose
in der mittagspause beschließen die
größten us-banken stützungskäufe
vergeblich der folgetag wird noch
schlimmer
die aktien fallen jetzt auch in london
paris und berlin
er geht als schwarzer freitag in die
geschichte ein
doch die kursverluste setzten sich bis
dienstag fort selbst strategische
anleger verfallen in panik und verkaufen
milliarden dollar sind vernichtet es
kommt zur weltwirtschaftskrise
es begann sich eben die moderne
kapitalistische wirtschaft zu entwickeln
und man erkannte noch nicht dass die
schwankungen die an einem solchen
wirtschaft normal sind und sehr heftig
ausfallen können dass man diesen
schwankungen auch begegnen kann dass man
etwas tun kann
in deutschland schlägt der reichskanzler
brüning 1930 einen radikalen sparkurs
ein
der falsche weg mit katastrophalen
auswirkungen preise fallen firmen können
nicht mehr kostendeckend produzieren und
entlassen massenhaft arbeiter die
nachfrage sinkt weiter ein teufelskreis
denn die junge weimarer republik nicht
überstehen wird
es wird heute davon gesprochen dass die
staaten auch versagt haben in dieser
situation man hat nicht nur
nicht gewusst wie man reagieren soll man
hat sogar auch falsch reagiert die
länder haben sich abgeschottet
es wurden zoll mauern hochgezogen viel
höher als wir das heute kennen und das
hat die ganze situation noch sehr
verschlimmert und vor allen dingen auch
so stark verlängert strafzölle und
handelskriege ein überhitzter
immobilienmarkt mit blasenbildung und
notenbanken die den markt mit billigem
geld versorgen anzeichen mehren sich die
einen neuen schwarzen tag befürchten
lassen
man wird in dem finanzsystem und in den
wirtschaftssystem wie wir es heute haben
auch solche schwankungen nie verhindern
können wesentlich ist dass die reaktion
wenn es denn auftritt dann energisch
sind um die auswirkungen abzumildern und
vor allen dingen die krise auch so kurz
wie möglich zu halten
ein kollaps der internationalen börsen
wird die deutsche wirtschaft zweifellos
hart treffen
doch die heutigen regierungen und
notenbanken sind krisenerprobt und
verfolgen meist eine antizyklische
wirtschaftspolitik donald trump
präsident und oberkommandierender der
streitkräfte der usa hat heute neue
kommandos gegeben
teile der us-truppen in syrien die ihm
für den schutz der kurdischen
verbündeten zu schade waren sollen nun
doch umkehren und im lande bleiben im
nordosten syriens gibt es ja
us-verteidigungsminister sp hat
angekündigt dass die usa soldaten und
gepanzerte fahrzeuge in den nordosten
syriens schicken
so solle verhindert werden dass die
terror miliz islamischer staat wieder
zugriff auf die ölfelder dort bekomme
präsident trump twitterte wir werden die
ölfelder niemals einem neuformierten es
überlassen jetzt kontrollieren syrische
kurden dort einige ölfelder
sie hatten sie von der terror miliz
zurückerobert die sich auch aus dem
ölverkauf finanzierte
in deutschland kommt immer mehr strom
aus erneuerbaren energien also aus wind
sonne oder biomasse nach branchenangaben
deckten erneuerbare energien knapp 43
prozent des stromverbrauchs in
deutschland das ist ein plus von fast 5
prozentpunkten und ein rekordwert frank
bethmann die branche klagt trotzdem
warum genau
naja aktuell ist der ausbau der
windenergie hierzulande quasi
eingebrochen da sind zum einen lange
genehmigungsverfahren aber auch zu wenig
ausgewiesene flächen und viele klagen
von bürgern die sich gegen neue
stromtrassen und windräder wären jetzt
sagt der fachverband aber wenn das so
weiter geht dann stehen tausende jobs
auf der kippe
jeder vierte arbeitsplatz sei bis 20.30
in gefahr derzeit arbeiten in der
windenergiebranche 64.000 menschen
anfang september gab es deswegen bereits
einen windkraft gipfel mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister zielsetzung
dringend bis jahresende ein paket mit
fördernden maßnahmen auf den weg bringen
denn auch für die bundesregierung steht
einiges auf dem spiel geht sie weltweit
doch als vorreiter bei der energiewende
beschlossen hat sie das bis 2022 das
letzte kernkraftwerk vom netz gehen soll
bis 20 38 ist dass sie keinen strom mehr
aus kohle
um das zu erreichen muss der ausbau der
erneuerbaren trotz der rekordzahlen
heute weitergehen
und ganz nebenbei boomte der bau von
windkraftanlagen besonders im ausland
und vor den küsten die internationale
energieagentur sieht ihr in den meeren
sogar einen multi milliarden markt
entstehen heißt es in ihrem jüngsten
bericht
vielen dank frank rund jeder elfte
beschäftigte in deutschland ist in den
vergangenen jahren am arbeitsplatz
sexuell belästigt worden das stellt die
antidiskriminierungsstelle des bundes
auf basis einer repräsentativen
befragung fest dabei sind die formen der
belästigung vielfältig sie reichen von
unangemessenen kommentaren und witzen
bis hin zu unerwünschten berührungen
familienministerin gefallen betonte
niemand müsse solche übergriffe
hinnehmen arbeitgeber seien per gesetz
dazu verpflichtet
für den schutz ihrer beschäftigten zu
sorgen in der fußball bundesliga hatte
mainz 05 am abend den ersten fc köln zu
gast beide vereine wollen raus aus dem
tabellenkeller
gelungen ist das heute abend mainz mit
einem 3 1-sieg in kalifornien brennen in
mehreren regionen große waldgebiete
starke winde treiben die flammen bis in
die vororte von los angeles und san
francisco
rund 50.000 menschen mussten ihre häuser
bereits verlassen
den einsatzkräften gelingt es bisher
nicht die feuer unter kontrolle zu
bekommen
möglicherweise müssen weitere
ortschaften geräumt werden damit
beschädigte leitungen nicht weitere
brände auslösen wurde in teilen des
us-bundesstaates der strom abgestellt
auf diesen felsen in der australischen
wüste kann man nicht schauen ohne
geheimnisse zu ahnen für das aborigines
folgt der anlage ist ihr guru der
felsenfeste beweis für ihre schöpfungs
legenden die auf den höhen und in den
höhlen des mächtigen roten felsens
spielen
so war dieser berg in heilig nur in
religiösen zeremonien durfte man ihm
nahe treten
das war den weißen eroberer dann wurscht
sie benannten den felsen nach einem
gouverneurs und sahen ihn als ein ding
das man halt besteigen muss um
triumphieren von oben runter zu kommen
jetzt aber bekommen die anderen berg
zurück schluss mit den klettertouren auf
ein heiligtum heute war dafür der letzte
tag und normen odenthal dort sein team
und er lieben dann auch heute schon
unten alles andere fanden sie hätte sich
heute falsch angefügt
wie vom himmel gefallen so liegt der dar
der uluru einsamer monolith in
australiens endlose steppe für einen
unbeweglichen riesen war das heute ein
ziemlich bewegender tag
er begann mit einer kleinen enttäuschung
kein aufstieg am morgen zu windig zu
gefährlich dabei sollte das doch die
letzte chance sein
ich will darauf auf jeden fall eher
aufstieg gehört zu den dingen die ich
unbedingt noch machen wollte aber moment
sieht schlecht aus
das ist schon nervig und heute ist der
letzte tag
künftige generationen werden das nicht
mehr erleben sehr ärgerlich zwei stunden
später haben wind und wetter ein
einsehen für alle die heute noch
unwiederbringliches erleben wollen eine
gute nachricht sie alle bezwingen den
berg gegen den willen der ureinwohner
die verehren den uluru als mystischen
ort der nicht betreten werden darf
legenden und sagen ranken sich die
weisheit soll hier zu hause sein dass
alles passt schlecht zu massenandrang
mit freizeitpark viele
die touristen sagen das sei ihr werk
aber das stimmt nicht
er gehört uns ureinwohnern für uns ist
der uno heilig und so muss er behandelt
und geschützt werden als heiligtum
die bitte nicht hochzuklettern gab es
schon lange und half nicht jetzt also
das verbot der uluru stand ewig auf
einer liste mir ziemlich egal was andere
leute an dem berg bedeutend finden ich
will einfach darauf und das mache ich
jetzt auch tut mir nur leid für alle
anderen die das nicht mehr kann
der felsen ein zankapfel
dabei müsse das nicht so sein meinen die
ureinwohner
was soll das wir versetzen doch hier
keinen berg komischer gedanke der ulu
bleibt hier er ist nicht weg jeder kann
ihn sehen er bleibt wo er ist
um wandern das geht besteigen nicht mehr
für manche kommt dieses verbot zu spät
37 menschen ließen ihr leben am hof
unterschätzten den steilen rutschigen
fels trotzdem ist heute nicht jeder
einsichtig manche aber schon
ich wollte unbedingt hoch und dann waren
wir im kulturzentrum und haben uns
informiert über das leben der aborigines
und auch über das heiligtum und mit
respekt auf dieses heiligtum habe ich
mich dagegen entschieden ab morgen
stellt sich die frage nicht mehr
der berg bekommt dann was er verdient
sagen die ureinwohner er bekommt endlich
ruhe und gut ist das wird ein
interessantes nachrichten wochenende
morgen am samstag entscheidet sich wie
die spd mitglieder über ihren
zukünftigen vorsitzenden bzw das duo das
den vor zeit haben wird denken in der
ersten runde und am sonntag sind die
landtagswahlen in thüringen
dabei wird es nicht bleiben sehen sie
dann noch ein ende
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir schauen zurück
auf den september und sehen hier die
globale temperatur abweichung der
september 2009 10 war zu warm es war
sogar der wärmste überhaupt bisher nun
auch in europa war es recht warm und wir
sehen nicht nur europa hier sehen die er
orangen töne also temperaturen eher zu
hoch und auch in der arktis war es viel
zu warm und so bildet sich derzeit das
winter als relativ langsam und es viel
zu niedrig zu warm ist es auch derzeit
über deutschland und so wird es auch
morgen sein aus dem südwesten europas
kommt warme luft und dieses hoch erwärmt
die luft weiterhin aber die kalte luft
liegt schon auf der lauer und kommt eine
am sonntag von nordwesten nach
deutschland schauen wir in die kommende
nacht an der nordsee gibt es viele
wolken und es regnet teils stürmische
böen aus südwest sonst bildet sich nebel
im süden an den alpen da klart es auf
und dann sinken die temperaturen bis auf
drei grad hieß es also am kältesten im
westen sind es 13 grad morgen im
tagesverlauf löst sich der nebel im
süden dann allmählich auf und es wird
sonnig in der mitte auch sonnige
abschnitte schnitte aber mehr wolken im
norden richtig dicht und vor allem an
der nordsee regen und stürmische böen
wieder aus südwestlichen richtungen
schauen wir auf die temperaturen
erreichen 21 grad im osten 22 im süden
sonst 15 bis 20 grad dass es viel zu
warm für ende oktober und am sonntag
wird es im süden noch einmal bis 22 grad
warm sonst setzt sich die kühle luft mit
regen von nordwesten her durch aber
schauen sie mal auf die nächsten tage
montag und dienstag vor allem dann nur
noch sechs bis zwölf grad damit ein
schöner abend